- Christ.
(swooshing)
(squeaky hinges)
(rock music)
- This is considered
the traditional staple
for most people most mornings.
(laughs)
We have the fried bread, English bacon,
which is English back bacon.
It's obviously a different
taste to the American bacon.
The pork sausage, which we have
made with our British butcher.
Um, Heinz baked beans, which are imported,
um, baked beans from England.
Fried tomatoes, grilled tomatoes here.
Then, underneath, we've
got fried mushrooms.
The black pudding, which is
also known as blood pudding.
Where I'm from, the West Midlands,
it's known as a delicacy.
- Ooh.
I think American bacon is better.
It's greasier, I mean
if you're going to get
something unhealthy, just,
like, go all the way, you know?
- This is really good,
it's really hearty, but...
I think ours is just a little bit better.
- This looks more like a hotdog.
- Mmmm.
- What my tastebuds are telling me
is that this is deep fried in butter,
and, um, it's fantastic.
- Mmm, oh my God.
- Who makes better toast?
England.
- I feel like it's so random to have
just a plain tomato for breakfast.
- While I'm not a big fan of tomatoes,
I can appreciate a tomato, and this is
a really, really good one.
- Mushrooms, they're ok.
I feel like these belong in an omelette.
On their own, uh, they seem lonely.
- [Woman] Are beans a vegetable?
- Also, beans...
Not a breakfast food in America.
- You know what, if I could have
the sauce of the beans, that's good.
- English breakfast is
basically like a barbeque.
- Black pudding is made of blood?
Lovely.
- It kind of looks like, uh...
corned beef hash.
- It's got, like, little nuggets in there.
I don't know what those are.
- I'm not a big fan of it on its own.
- Pudding is chocolate,
and dessert and sweet.
You told me I'm going
to have black pudding!
- Listen, I mean this has been
a very interesting experience,
but, to be honest, I still think that
the American breakfast is the strong one.
- English breakfast is better than
American breakfast, I'm sorry.
- This or Cinnamon Toast Crunch?
I think this wins.
- Gotta give it to America,
cause, America, you can
have dessert for breakfast,
you can have, you know, like you can have
something sweet, you can
have something savory.
This just feels like dinner.
So it's a tie?
I think we might have just started
a second Revolutionary War.
(rock music)
(swooshing)
(squeaky hinges)